álvaro tiene una biblioteca en el centro
de parís está especializada en los vinos
naturales biodinámicos ecológicos y
orgánicos cuando la fundó hace cinco
años era un producto desconocido
tuve que enseñar mucho explicar mucho al
principio porque la gente me pedía más
por dos clásicos órganos clásicos y me
decía no conocemos las referencias que
tiene que son muy extraños sus vinos que
poco a poco la gente les gustó mucho y
ha ido creciendo sobre todo la juventud
esta tarde participa de una degustación
de vinos naturales producidos en chile
comido obliga el evento se realiza a
distancia ya recibió anticipadamente su
kit de degustación
en la oficina de promoción de chile en
parís el objetivo es penetrar el difícil
mercado francés por eso en una pandemia
es impedimento para realizar la
degustación si bien chile es el cuarto
exportador de vinos del mundo francia le
sigue siendo esquiva durante años el
público francés ha visto al vino chileno
como un producto masivo o de baja gama
el mercado de los vinos bio es una
puerta que se abre en términos del
orgánico en general hay una tendencia
mundial hacia este tipo de vinos y en
francia- vemos como en el resto del
mundo que la oferta no alcanzará
satisfacer la demanda y acá vemos una
verdadera oportunidad para los vinos
chilenos porque somos una isla
fitosanitaria tenemos la cordillera de
los andes tenemos el océano tenemos al
norte el desierto más seco del mundo y
al sur tenemos glaciar esto hace que
estemos realmente muy aislados en
burdeos y él lo que importa vinos
chilenos hace más de 20 años ya tiene
unos 40 crudos de 14 viñas diferentes un
20 por ciento son vinos
hace unos 20 años el consumo era sobre
todo de restaurantes latinoamericanos
hoy hay una base de clientes mucho más
grande jóvenes que han viajado se han
informado y quieren descubrir
la degustación pudo hacerse sin
problemas a distancia los organizadores
esperan que la acogida positiva se
traduzca en mejores ventas